REGULA AND
THE CATS.
AROUND THE FAR WING.
VERSION WILL SLAP IT WITH
>> Alan: ONLY FIVE AND A HALF
I DON'T KNOW WHY BRANDON HAGEL
S
HE HAS TO BE CAREFUL.
LINDELL INCHES IN BEHINDGOAL FOO
CAME INTO THIS IN FRONT.
THAT GETS IN FRONTTHIS SHOT BRE.
A SOLID PERIOD.
TALKING TO JAKE HEAVINESS.
>> Alan: OH, LOOK AT THAT
SHOT!
OFF THE PIPEACROSS.
WATCH 4 IN RED.
HE'S GOING TO COME ACROSS.
BARKOV DROPSTHEN OUT TO THE  NE
ON THETHE GLOVE AND THE
PAD OF MARC-ANDRE THIS
HOCKEY GAME.  ILL IF THE OPENIN.
>> Eddie: BEAUTIFUL PLAY THE T
HIS BROTHER CALEB, SO EVERYBODY
IN RED HAD TO COME TOUCHOF THE
NET.
BUT DEBRINCAT MADE A HECK OF A R
THAT PASS THERE, AVOID
>> Alan: STROME
IN.
THERE GOES THE "FLOWER" TO THE
BENCH.
SO THE
THE FAR